thanks Jen and Jim Cavanaugh is the CEO
of worldwide technology one of the
biggest employers here in st. Louis but
also one of the top companies in the
country I believe Forbes ranked you guys
51st on the largest private owned
companies welcome to the show
thanks for having me it's great to be
here tell us a little bit more about
your company worldwide technology is a
global systems integrator so we provide
large fortune 500 companies governments
around the world large service providers
the complex integration technology
integration it goes into running
companies and organizations data center
cloud cybersecurity and we actually have
a whole team of application developers
that write mobile apps on top of those
those technology environments sounds
exciting and also cryptic well certainly
you know the business but you're also in
another business that's interesting
you're interested in bringing Major
League Soccer yes
st. Louis yes about that I yes I
actually played soccer growing up you
know as a kid at played at st. Louis
University which is just down the street
from where we are here played
professional soccer for a number of
years actually played for the Olympic
team back in 83 and 84 so I had a good
fortune of traveling around the world
it's kind of interesting what you guys
are doing here with chess that soccer is
such a multicultural global sport and
chess seems to be the same it is some
similarities in regards to those two but
we think that soccer from me from my
perspective and the MLS is important one
I've got a passion for the game of
soccer because I think it's just good
for a number of different reasons the
development of kids on and off the field
character similar to how I think chess
can be applied to help develop kids but
it's also something that I believe is
good for the community so if you think
about all the things are going on with
sports teams businesses chess
I think cities need to be more
progressive in regards to bringing
activity to downtown cities and
it's not just one thing that really
drives that it's it's an ecosystem of
partners and things going on so long
long answer to your question where we're
at a point now we're very close to
bringing animal s team to st. Louis I
believe there's a vote in a couple of
days proper one in proper - I didn't
hear about that
no I'm just kidding no I've been up to
my ears in kind of campaigning for this
vote which is Tuesday of this week and
we feel that we've made a lot of
progress - to connect it's not just
about soccer it's about giving back to
the community it's building this
multi-purpose stadium that was a
beautiful looking for proposed stadium
downtown yes
it is and once again not too far from
where we are here and it's right next to
Union Station and that's the thing that
excites me even when I look at the
picture it's it's creating an ecosystem
of activity in the downtown city that
feeds upon each other to develop a more
progressive City and and I think
bringing that activity also improves the
security activity brings more people
that not only creates more jobs more
activity more interaction between
different different organizations but
then also it's a sport that I love and
and and I think it's just a great sport
of soccer so absolutely and chess is a
sport that I love and and certainly
there's some economic impact for having
this chess club here in st. Louis and we
have some challenges trying to broaden
the appeal what are the challenges that
you face doing the same thing in soccer
I you know it is interesting I think
there's definitely parallels between the
two soccer in the United States even 10
or 20 years ago it has come a long long
way so I think that opportunity is there
for chess also and and I think it's
something that it can take time but
there's also I think once the ball
starts rolling and you create that
momentum it really builds and it can
build in a significant way just like if
you looked at soccer in the United
States
five or 10 years ago you had franchises
out there that if they're trying to
bring a new franchise to a new city it
was mainly one or two investor groups or
cities vying for that next franchise
today they're looking for two franchises
in two different cities there's 12
investor groups 12 different cities and
you know the the last two franchises
just got awarded one was in Atlanta that
I wouldn't consider just an incredibly
big sports town but their first game
that they had there their first opener
was 56,000 people that they had and they
sold 27,000 season tickets so it says a
lot about the momentum and I think
there's a lot of parallels to chess I
think just has such a great ability to
connect to kids
inner city schools it can be a great
teacher I think of kids to think more
strategically especially in the day and
life of everything is immediate
gratification everything's you know
responding to your phone social media so
I think to be able to pull kids back and
even you know adults moving into other
roles to think more strategically I
think chess could be a great teacher
well I've been doing that for thirty
years so I know it is a great teacher
and I initiated my own company
millionaire chess to do a big idea
a million-dollar chess tournament we did
it three years in a row wasn't easy at
all we had to just pass on this year so
I was interested in the challenges of
something like like soccer but I've
heard that you're a big chess players I
see were in college is this the case we
you know it does it brings I've fond
memories of i well first I'll qualify
was not a big chess player but I really
enjoyed they did play chess so it's very
interesting that and again not too far
from here we had a house in the city
that had a porch out in front it would
be a day like this that we would be out
a bunch of buddies and people would be
getting around and we're out on a porch
and we just get the chessboard out nerd
beam um of us playing chess and
competing against each other and you
know it's something I really enjoyed and
I'm not exactly sure how that really
came about
we do it but I do have fond memories of
playing chess and competing with a
number of different guys on a soccer
team that even had houses across the
street so it was uh it was a great
experience and I'm not surprised that
chess player ends up being CEO Jim Gavin
oh thank you so much worldwide
technologies keep doing great work thank
you and good luck to you guys thank you